Hallo, um es zu fragen, es sei denn, wir kombinieren
Video Yellow Chingada jedes Mal, wenn wir
nach Monaten der Vereinigung aktueller Kaduche
genau so viel haben, wie Sie ihn kennen, da er nicht
in Bankgeschäfte investiert, damit sie weiß, wie
ich einkaufe
Distrito 35s coolste Ich bin
Ratschläge August Ich denke, Mond, Sie
haben bis zu unserem Sangha-Zine jede glückliche
Freude für mich Jason Derulo von Infomercials
Drachenspiele im Hotel
Dies kommt, als Siliziumtalente
Tanisha nach Luft schnappt Sandig Ich werde nie glücklich, dass
er Büroarbeit vermittelt  sind viel
zu viel mehr Nicht-Kunden-Video
Saddam ist besorgt, eine Geisel von seinem
Kind in Australien zu nehmen, hätte weniger Lieder,
gut, das Telefon ist
gekappt  eins und
er ist wirklich giftig, dass ich sponsere.
Ich dachte, ich dachte, wissen Sie, fühlen Sie sich
vertraut, Bundy, das Büro, wir arbeiten
genau so, wie sich vermischen, ok,
Rechnung, Mike, Antworter, der nie ausgegeben hat,
Chef Enosh, unsere Denker, klammern Morgan
sc  oot in
[Musik]
es ist all unsere Besucher Wut kommt, was ich
bin uns online bei Lächeln zoologisch in seinem
Helden Indien um am besten in der Natur fragt einen
europäischen Phallus Mehta meistens von dem
getesteten ihn über die Grenze Kapitän
Ling, den ich draußen hier im Geschäft gefunden habe
Agenda Ornish und auf Kameras wie Mathe
Klausur Klausur der Saison neulich noch ein
Pink auf und Shopper Zeuge Pärchen
[Musik]
soweit auf der Lizenzierung schön
euch zu treffen wie was ich war pleite ja mir geht es gut
also ähm hoffe es gefällt euch  in Deutschland, oh Mann,
ich habe Städter immer bevorzugt, ich kann nicht sagen, dass
du alleine magst,
ich liebe Köln, ich meine, es ist
wunderschön  Dinge
wie ein Block, es ist auf und auf der Brücke,
ähm, wir müssen die Kirche sehen, okay, nein,
Soße, wir müssen es sehen, okay, was für das
Wetter, es ist nicht, nein, letzte Woche war es
sehr heiß, aber ja, du kommst, es ist blutig, ich weiß nicht.
Dieses Wetter macht mir nichts aus, ich meine
besonders heute Morgen, wenn du läufst  Und
du willst nicht, dass es zu heiß wird, also war
es eigentlich, es war eigentlich ziemlich schön,
okay, ja, ich bin du, Chiba, ich weiß nicht, ich
muss fragen, ich habe mir gestern einen YouTube-Kanal angesehen
und du hast eine neue
Single  ja ja ja, wenn ich Glück habe,
ja nein, ich habe vor vier Tagen gehört, oh äh, das
meiste von meiner statischen YouTube-Seite, von der ich
dich kenne, in meinem Kopf und schlucke ein bisschen
NZ und ja, Nacht, schöne Sache, du
siehst dir YouTuber an, du hast Lieblings-
YouTuber aus Großbritannien  oder Amerika oder
vielleicht Deutschland, du kennst jemanden, den
du kennst, ich stehe viel auf YouTube und
all das Zeug, aber ich mag es,
einfach herumzuspringen, aber ich habe
mit einem YouTuber zusammengearbeitet, sein Name ist
Matt Steffanina, okay, bin  Ich habe
mit ihm bei Dancer The Dance zusammengearbeitet, ja, ich weiß,
ja, Mitarbeiter, wenn ich Glück habe, ja,
Lyric-Video, ja, das jetzt rauskommt, okay,
wenn du dir das anschaust,
Rocky-Core-Choreographie, ja, ich weiß, du
hast viele Tattoos,
ich habe eine Frage, wann  wann hast du
dein erstes tätowieren gemacht in welchem ​​alter
weil ich m  Ich weiß es nicht und ich möchte
tätowieren, aber immer, wenn ich zu meiner Mutter gehe
und sagen wir, Mama, ich möchte tätowieren,
sagt sie, ich werde dich hassen, wenn du dazu neigst,
nein, es ist verrückt, das ist lustig, dass du das sagst
, weil ich tatsächlich meine habe  Erstes
Tattoo von meiner Mutter, oh ja, Mama, wenn du es
siehst, ja, ich war acht Jahre alt, ähm, und
ja, ja, ja, ich war ein Tom, und ich machte mich
fertig für die Kirche, und ich war, ich habe
es geleitet, ich bin gerannt, um dich
etwas wissen zu lassen  um die
Ecke, okay, Mama hatte ein Bügeleisen neben sich und
sie drehte sich um und schlug mir
damit mit dem Bügeleisen ins Gesicht, also habe ich so eine
kleine kleine Narbe, also ist es nicht das
coolste Tattoo, aber weißt du, jetzt bin ich es
nicht, weißt du  Ich will tätowieren, ja, du
hast viele, viele Lieder, ich kenne dich,
seit ich 12 bin.
Ich weiß nicht, ist nicht in meinem Kopf, ja,
ja, was ist dein Lieblingslied?
Das heißt, es gibt so viele verschiedene
Fehler, ja, und du weißt, dass
es Songs für alles gibt, was
ich bin  wie wenn ich Single bin, weißt du, dass
ich es liebe, alleine zu fahren, okay, weißt du, ich
sage, und wenn ich es bin, weißt du, ich versuche es zu tun,
versuche, auf eine Party zu kommen, bewege es, ich
liebe dich sehr, ja, wenn ich es bin
Ich werde eines Tages heiraten. Wahrscheinlich weißt du,
dass es wirklich von der Zeit abhängt, mich zu heiraten,
und wenn ich Glück habe, ist das auch
einer meiner Favoriten.
Mein Glück hat eine
sehr tote Seite, aber es ist auch sehr
emotional, ja ähm, und es ist ein wirklich cooles
Konzept, jemanden zu treffen, den
du auf der anderen Seite kennst,
weißt du, nur weil ich die andere Seite wirklich mag,
ist es mein Lieblingsdanke  du
fragst ich ich hoffe es ist okay ähm ich muss
fragen wer dein coolster
kontakt in deinen handys ist
ähm ich schätze es kommt drauf an wen
du cool findest ich meine von den dailies bis hin zu
lady gaga du kennst nicki minaj nett und
vielleicht a  Frage an mich, was denkst du,
ist mein Hauptinhalt auf YouTube, wenn du
mich ansiehst, bin ich ein Single  r oder einfach ähm,
ich würde sagen, dein Hauptinhalt ist, dass
du in einer Boyband bist, also mag ich, okay
selbst, du würdest den Leadsänger
Yam bekommen und dann hast du zwei andere Typen
bei dir, okay Mann, singst du das,
ja, ich  versuche zu singen, aber erst seit zwei
Monaten mache ich verrückte Sachen.
Ich habe gerade Inhalte gemacht, die
mir Spaß machen
das ganze Wochenende war eine Woche lang ein Block
und du nur Amy das ja
sonst nichts nein was hast du zugenommen
nein es ist okay aber du fühlst dich okay nach
drei Tagen fühlst du dich ein bisschen es ist ein
verrücktes Gefühl wenn du aufwachst und
der Tag  Vorher hast du nur McDonald gegessen und
vor zwei Tagen nur McDonald, aber nach
sieben Tagen sagte ich okay, nein, ist okay und
ja, ich habe ein kleines Geschenk, nicht für dich,
aber für die nächsten zehn Minuten können wir
dich schon mal probieren, bevor
es dramatisch wird  ja, das ist spät, vielleicht
können wir es durch die Hitze fliegen  el room and
cry okay nice
[Musik]
Nein
wir brauchen eine Versicherungsgesellschaft, damit das
aufhört, das ist der größte Spaß, den ich bei
Luminos hatte,
nimm das Ding, denn das wird enden
In the Lake of em habe ich viele
jüngere Zuschauer und Mädchen, Jungs, und ich sage,
schickte mir Bilder von dir, und wir werden
ihr Alter erraten, nein, ich gestern, ich sage
es in Snapchat und Instagram, yo, morgen
werde ich Jason Derulo treffen und mir schicken
Bilder von dir, also habe ich ein paar Bilder
mit meinen Freunden und meinen Leuten,
die sich meine Videos für dich ansehen, und vielleicht
kannst du das Alter herausfinden, aber es
wäre schön für sie, wenn sie
Jason sehen, du schätzst mein Alter, ich bin wirklich  Gut
im Raten, ja okay, wir werden sehen,
denn das ist mein bester Kanal. Ich bin,
du weißt, ich singe und ich tanze und so,
ja, Sachen, aber mein Bestes ist, das
Alter zu schätzen, das wir sehen werden, weil ich
denke, ob es ein Mädchen gibt, das 14 Jahre alt ist
alt und voller Make-up Ich sage immer,
sie ist 18, ja, weil du kein Profi bist, okay
, fangen wir an  o was denkst du wie alt
siebzehn siebzehn ja
sie ist 19 cool ich hab das falsch verstanden
was siehst du an ihr
sie oh sie ist sie muss 2020 sein aber sie ist
ich sehe du weißt also jetzt vielleicht 17 17 er ist
mein bruder er ist 60 sonst nah
Ja, hört zu Leute, ich bin nicht gut
in eurer Show zu sein.
Ja, schaut euch die neue Single an, wenn ich Glück habe.
Teil, um die Regel zu ändern.
Danke, okay, lügt nicht
Off Soda 1000 gleichnamige Cuba Soda Lügen Sie nicht
zu dieser Vasodilatation Subic-Ventil
vereinheitlichen Megan Schwamm auf Mann Scheck Garnitur
Dies ist eine nette Einladung, so wie mit Encanta-
Untergang in Kenia neue Mingus-Bascomb-
Autowerkstatt ohne Boris Petis getrimmt wird
Ich bin ein Laster,
weiß, dass Devon Alec sich auch in einer
Abkühlung abgekühlt hat, die in der Suche nach einer offenen
Veranstaltung wie einer schönen Kunst im Geschäft
ist
Auto kann auch kommen, aber
immer noch mein Lied kurz genug für wenn  Ich habe
Glück, dass ich auf Miyabi Nullen so umreiße